at this topic it's going to be we're
going to take a look at the games of
Magnus Carlsen anybody familiar with who
is Magnus Carlsen no he's the number one
rated player in the world
he is only 22 years old and by many he
is considered to be the future world
champion so he is basically high rated
something like 70 points then the next
player on a rating list okay so we'll
take a look at two of his games quick
wins it's not going to be a very long
games quick wins by Magnus Carlsen and
then we're going to do tactics and the
team for the tactics they will be called
mix motifs okay so it's not going to be
just a double check or double attack we
did last time it's gonna be mix motifs
so it's going to be a lot of different
tactical ideas to find okay again I want
everybody to pay close attention and if
I ask you a question make sure you raise
your hand first okay
okay so we're going to begin with this
game we play between Magnus Carlsen
the highest ranked player in the world
and Fabiano Caruana another very strong
Grandmaster so Carlsen is playing with
the white pieces
efore c5 what is the name of this
opening yes Sicilian defense okay so you
should be very familiar with this
opening because this is one of the most
popular openings one of the most popular
openings so it's remembered II for c5 is
the Sicilian defense so Carlsen played
Knight f3 d6 now the main line here is
d4 but he often oftentimes he doesn't
play just the main lines you just play
something to to take his opponent out of
the theory so if they g3 he's trying to
Theon settle his Bishop and just Castle
white is not aiming for some big
advantage in the opening just trying to
get the pieces out and castle
three black also wants to put the bishop
on the same diagonal this should be
seven it's very important to know that
every time opponent makes a move the
first thing you need to do is you need
to stop and ask yourself the question
what is the idea behind his last move so
for example in this position he just
played Bishop d7 do you see the idea
behind his last move what is Caruana one
of the top grandmasters he's I think
ranked 6th in the world right now what
is he trying to do with this move he
just played Bishop d7 what is the idea
behind this move yes exactly
he is attacking the pawn on e4 see if
you don't pay attention if you just
think about okay I got a castle right
away this will be a blunder because he
will just take the pawn and then you
lose your center point okay so remember
every time opponent makes a move you ask
yourself this question what is the idea
behind his last move this way you can
avoid blundering and bond during a pawn
or piece or maybe even missing a
checkmate so try to see the idea behind
opponent's last move so why place Queen
e2
because he wants to protect the pawn now
d6 in a Sicilian defense the common idea
for white is to play d4 to be able to
get a control of the score without
playing d4 it's very difficult to fight
for any advantage so this move d4 it's
played almost always for what by white
because he needs to play this otherwise
no advantage so he takes 94 yes
now yes yes the bishop is protecting the
pawn Knight f6 played castle 9b d7 I
want to get to the important moment here
which is a great rook d1 and black
played a6 controlling the B 5 squared
and here this last move a 6 by Caruana
is a blunder okay
it's a it's a blunder and now White has
a very strong move here very strong idea
that he can try to do and basically he
is winning so you need to think about it
and find the winning idea for white one
bad move and suddenly buck is losing now
spend some time spend few minutes think
about I try to say it has to be a very
strong idea it's not like a regular
developing move because if you develop
you will develop also so it's a very
strong tactical idea you have to
calculate a little bit okay it involves
an idea called discovery attack okay you
make a move and then suddenly you
discover the attack there can be a
couple of tactics you need to calculate
but afterwards white is winning yes
yes go ahead yeah well Bishop to h3 it's
just you're making a move developing
move but your your pawn is hanging now
because he has two pieces attacking so
it's again it's not just a regular
developing move it's a very strong idea
discovery idea think about it yes
Ponte trades it's okay move but you're
defending see this is defending but
there is a very strong move that you can
try to make in order to try to attack
try to look for a move that attack
something not just the defending move
yes excellent 'if I've this is the
discovery idea you advance your pawn and
then you attack the knight attack the
bishop so you have to pay close
attention now because it's going to be
tactic a little bit now so for example
he cannot just take Knight takes pawn
because after you take the bishop you
wrap a piece white is up piece now so
after e5 he played Bishop takes g2 now
you can capture two minor pieces the
bishop or a knight which move is the
best very important here which move is
the best here yes
which piece you have to capture here go
ahead
aha Knight pawn takes f6 okay absolutely
because if you captured the bishop here
this is not going to do anything he will
just simply capture the piece capture
the pawn now so that's why you don't
wanna de you take now now his bishop is
hanging now he played the both Bishop h3
which is the only move by the way but
let's say he goes back we should be
seven this is a bit a bit a bit very
advanced but I think you can find it
okay now a very strong tactical idea for
white because opponent King is in the
middle of the board when it's in the
middle of the ball we think about the
tactical possibilities so what can we do
to take advantage of that now a strong
tactic and you win the game yes
excellent Knight takes c6 sacrificing
the knight attacking the Queen so he has
to take continued check King cannot go
anywhere if he puts the Queen in front
we just take the Queen so he has to
bring the bishop and now don't rush when
you see a good move you look for a
better one okay so here yeah you can
just take the bishop and you're probably
much better but you look for a better
move yes F captures g7 very good and now
suddenly the rook is trapped also so
white is winning easily now rook cannot
go anywhere if it goes to g8 we just
take it he cannot go to f8 we take it so
that's why in this position he cannot go
back Bishop b7 because of the 96 very
strong tactic okay we're going to go on
after I show you this game we're going
to go do an over review also okay so
you'll have a chance to
find this moves also so so Caruana
decided that this is just winning for
white so he played the only move Bishop
h3 and now after the next move after the
next strong move for white white is
winning a piece very strong move
the blocking is in the middle of the
board and he's behind in development
this is the biggest problem for him yes
you want to go here yeah but you could
do that but that just you're just
attacking see that I could move the
Queen if you attack me I will just move
the Queen and unfortunately we cannot
just take here anymore because that was
the purpose behind the smoke to protect
so he defended 96 threat now but there
is a problem now for him with the bishop
on h3 this bishop is very awkward
see this bishop is not very well placed
now and Carlsen makes the right move and
go ahead
pawn to g4 you could do that but that
just blocks the bishop it's a possible
move but you have something stronger can
you try to find a move that immediately
attacks the bishop and the bishop
doesn't have many squares to go to you
could do that that's a move but you need
to attack the bishop that's yeah it's a
normal move but try to think of a
different idea try to attack his bishop
I need you to find a move that you make
with white now and you attack the bishop
and the bishop has no good squares to go
to can you see that move can you see the
move yes excellent Queen h5 attacking
the bishop see this bishop doesn't have
many squares to go to if he goes to g4
you simply take it and if it goes in
Bishop f5 you take he takes now just go
back check it's not a mate but it's just
the white is just winning a piece at
least because now you cannot put the
bishop here he just takes if you move
the knight first you take on g7 and now
when opponent has a pink piece like this
and this is a cold
what kind of pin is this absolute pin
right so when there is a pinned piece
which piece you want to use to attack
the pinned piece yes
pawn absolutely well when the pin is
piece is pinned you use a pawn to attack
the pinned piece you play a4 and then
you win a piece okay so that's why you
win the knight and the game so that's
why in this position after Queen h5
basically they play a few more moves you
played Queen takes f6 but it's really
after Queen takes h3 as you can see here
right is up a minor piece for a pond
basically night for the pond this is not
enough compensation so after I can just
show you what happened just a few more
moves Bishop e7 plate Carlson went
Knight c3 Queen g6 96 95 he took the
bishop and after Bishop f4 Caruana
resigned because you know at the he's
just down a piece down on a piece his
King is also in the middle of the board
okay so by just playing the e5 move see
you have to always look for this kind of
discovery ideas good let's take a look
at now the second game okay and mainly I
want to take a look at this idea it was
a very nice idea that he used okay in
this game Carlson is playing black okay
so let's let's get to that position okay
Knight f3 d6 Knight f6 Knight BD to d4
Bishop d3 castle castle 96 eat c3e five
black is fighting for the center and now
after HD he wants to bring the Knight to
f4 this is where he wants to do he went
to here to go here now he takes Knight
f4 attacking the light square Bishop now
see in this position when opponent he
just took the night the most logical
thing to do is just to recapture but can
you find a very strong in-between move
in between wins when without capturing
you try to make a strong move here that
creates a strap very strong trade here
can you find a strong in-between move
here for black yes well well which move
is it you need to have a move here which
more how about this we have a 90th that
is attacking here right can we make a
move here immediately to try to threaten
a checkmate because checkmate threat is
very strong right you make a move and
then you threaten checkmate so what can
you do yes Queen g5 okay Queen g5
because now he can move his knight back
if you want but then you're going to
take the pawn on g2 with a checkmate so
let's say he goes back
checkmate okay so Queen g5 threatening
the mate so he goes Knight g4 he takes
Nightbeat 392 check he cannot take the
queen is guarding it now he takes White
King is really in trouble here so I want
to get to the crucial moment here rook
takes e4 rookie fan okay this is the
real game by played by the number one
player in the world why black to play
black to play checkmate
into black to play checkmate you just
raise your hand if you think you have it
just raise your hand
let's spend a little bit more time let's
give everybody a chance to find it
checkmate into what that means you have
to do something really special right it
doesn't look like this opposition you
can just checkmate right but it's a very
special move here you have and you have
to remember this idea because you can
use in your games okay
think about a checkmate in two
okay yes take the pawn you could do that
but then what about if he takes your
night so he takes the night and now he
can escape with a king because that
night is doing something very important
that night is controlling the g1 square
so if somehow we can check him right it
could be in trouble
so that's why you don't have time to
take upon here you need to do something
forcing right away you need to do
something forcing right away let's see
okay go ahead Queen to h5 a lot of times
the good move you have is actually you
take a piece from one side of the board
from Queen side you take it to the other
side of the board
Queen h5 check for a moment it looks
like a blunder right you can just take
the Queen
but when he takes your queen it removes
the pawn from the fourth-ranked right
and now what do you do
rook takes h4 checkmate
okay so the very strong idea this is a
little bit harder to see because it's
their own honest on a sideways you know
so it's not like on a file on the rank
so it's a little bit less common but
it's a very strong idea here okay
now we're going to move on to the
tactics involving mixed motifs okay
first position this might be a bit easy
but we'll start out with this one and
they're going to move on a little bit
more difficult positions white to play
checkmate in two so as you can see black
is up material is upper rook and a
bishop but there is a problem for black
here first you need to realize what is
the problem with the black position
there is only one problem but it's very
very big problem for him first you find
that and then after that you're going to
be able to find the way to take
advantage of it okay so it's white to
play and win now you have to win very
quickly okay raise your hand if you
think you have it
who can tell me what is the problem with
the blacks position just that for now
what is the problem with the blacks
position yes
no no not it's not it's not no it's not
that it's I mean that's a problem too
but that's not the most important what's
the main problem
okay so problem is the king right
black has a back ranked problem okay so
black has a background problem that's
the main idea so you need to find a way
to take advantage of that now think
about what can you do to take advantage
of the background okay let's see all
right yes in the back yeah
if you move your look down you can take
with the bishop right
okay so you play what's the first move
first move rookie a but then he takes
now see then he also blocked the back
rank okay you got the idea but you have
to play a little bit different move
order okay if you if you improve the
move order your idea will work so you
have to improve the move order okay yes
yeah
Quincy eight very good check now you're
deflecting the defender this is what
it's called deflecting the defender now
defender is the bishop by doing this
check you simply deflect this piece he
has to take no choice and if it takes
what do you do well yeah but then you go
here
check mate with the Queen so he takes
and now what do you do continue rook to
e8 checkmate okay so this idea you
sacrifice your queen to deflect the
defender okay when you deflect it then
you go down with the checkmate solve the
biggest problem is the background okay
the background is weak and by
sacrificing the Queen forcing him take
we take advantage of that okay all right
moving forward okay now I have a
difficult one okay
this was just to kind of warm up and now
we have a difficult one looks like white
is just losing from the first glance
because he is down lots of material here
down exchange down three pounds and it
looks like a matter of few more moves
until black develops these pieces to
completely neutralize some of the
activity but here you have a very very
strong move and then white is winning
basically you're winning in two moves
here - three moves and you're winning
Oh get the think about it don't rush
raising your hand this is not that easy
okay you have to think let's spend a
couple of minutes on this position
again I suggest double-checking your
answer sir if you raise your hand
double-check your answer make sure
you're also playing the good defense for
black you have to see the good defense
to white to play and win
okay yes night
okay night the where do you want to move
this night here
I could just take quintics so your but
think think do you think about it here
we need something very strong here okay
something very strong we need here now
yes wait wait yeah go ahead
well you could do that but the thing is
this is just you make a move you attack
and I push and I defend okay so you need
something more this is a kind of
position we did something really special
okay this is not just a regular move you
need if you thinking of regular move I
don't think you have it okay
you need something extraordinary here
okay something very extraordinary move
okay to put them into a mating net now
let's see yes Knight to h5 do you see
that I can take your queen and what do
you do they have a follow-up check okay
and we don't have anything to follow it
up with okay you're getting closer
you're getting closer now let's see
getting closer now yes
a thiamine h5 this is a five yeah but if
you want the Queen to h5 I can just take
you know what I know but you're just
exchanging Queens when you down exchange
in three pounds you don't want to
exchange the Queen's because your only
hope is to find a way to checkmate your
opponent okay if you go to endgame you
down to much material you're going to
lose okay so it's very important not to
exchange pieces remember when you
download some material you definitely
don't want to exchange pieces especially
your Queen because queen a lot of times
can offer you some chances again you
have to have a very special move it's
not a regular move okay yes very strong
good job Knight to g6 okay let's wait
okay let's let raise hand yeah if so
nine to six let's take a look now why
this move is very strong if it takes the
Queen now what do you do now what do we
do here which Knight
9 de 7 de 7 checkmate see the Knights
are very strong one Knight is guarding
the square other night is checkmating so
now and if it takes here what do you do
okay go ahead
no Queen I trade I take yes behind if I
take how about we play simple
can we play simple okay alright then we
win the game okay see when you're
winning you play simple okay you don't
need to complicate anything when you're
winning now let's see if it takes now
the night what can you do now I need you
to find the checkmate if you think you
win the Queen it's not enough I need you
to find the checkmate in checkmate here
let's see
he has some checkmate ideas now it
actually takes a little bit longer so
what's the first move first move yes 97
check now continue yeah you could take
with the night but it's better to take
with the rook first okay because now
he's going to come and attack you and
then he can't attack you this is a
different type of now position checkmate
in two y2 klay checkmate in two now yes
me
oh wait wait okay so this is the
position right so white goes check black
has to go here no choice right so you we
take right no no it's check yeah so
always remember when it's check King is
under check you gotta move so he goes
here now he plays Bishop e6 and now
checkmate in two let's see check maybe
to make sure you have the right answer
yeah it's a nice idea you put them into
a mating net let's see who has the
checkmate in two now yes
Queen takes h7 check sacrificing the
queen he has to take what do you do yes
checkmate that is the mating net okay
that is a very strong mating net white
to play and win no no just just find a
win I don't want to tell you how many
moves because that will make it easier
so let's think black is doing good looks
like he's got some extra pounds and if
you take his Bishop he is ready to start
checking you so it could be a problem so
you have to find a way to do something
because you could lose this
again this is an example where you need
to remove the defender okay there is
this defender that is stopping you from
checkmating him so what you need to do
is you need to remove this defender and
after you do that then you're going to
be able to checkmate him okay so you
remove the defender okay
okay which piece you think is the
defender here that is stopping from
checkmate
which piece is defender yes which piece
black bishop yes that's the defender if
we can eliminate that defender we have a
way to checkmate right so let's try to
find the way we can do it okay continue
with what well the problem with that is
when you take with a pawn you I can
start checking you okay you give me time
to start checking you so you won't have
time for just taking you need to do it
you need to make it full sync okay you
have to make it forcing yes but that's
not the defender right the defender is
the bishop it's defending something very
important so defender is the bishop we
need to do something about that bishop
okay now what can we do here yes
aha well the thing is you're doing this
without eliminating the defender then he
takes King takes and you're down three
pounds okay so we could lose this now
okay so we can lose this think about it
think about it you'll find it you need
to eliminate the defender but you have
to do it the forcing okay so he cannot
have time to start giving the checks
what do you do after we remove the
defender yes
you know it okay let's see okay yes
with what well see somebody say that
already if you take with the pawn you
give me time to check you you give me
time to check you okay you give me time
to check you so you don't want to give
me that time okay so it needs to be
something else yes yes going back well
yeah but that wouldn't help us there see
our goal is to take this piece off the
board what can we do but we want to make
sure it's for sink okay yes very good
check now
check he has to take now continue go
ahead no no you took one before I take
what was the idea remember idea is to
mate now yeah
checkmate okay you remove the defender
defender is the bishop but the way you
have to remove it you have to remove it
with a check okay if you don't do it
with the check it's not going to work
okay so you have to do it with the check
let's go over this again okay we start
off with which move which move check he
has to take it no choice and now
continue p6e 6v6 that be a B right ABCD
so that b6 okay so this is removing the
defender but not really just taking it
taking it with a check so he doesn't
have time to defend okay white to play
this just right out of the opening he
just played Bishop c5 bishop from a 7 c5
and now this is a blunder white to play
and win a piece ok just raise your hand
if you think you have it yeah let's see
white to play and win a piece we're not
looking for a checkmate we're just
looking for a way to win a piece
so there is a piece that blackheads in
the center that is not very well placed
and we can try to put pressure on that
piece first we put pressure forcing him
back and then he retreats to a certain
square where we can try to for Kim okay
so that's what you got to try to do here
okay let's see raise your hand if you
have it raise your hand okay
yes in the back pawn to c4 is a
possibility but the problem with this
move is I just retreat and you don't
have a follow-up okay now so we can just
play there because he just goes back and
we don't have a good follow up okay so
we need something better okay we need to
attack that face but we have to do it
different way let's see how can we do
that huh to win a piece here yes yeah
part two before I just take no I just
take it doesn't help you okay you need
to attack something else something else
yes yeah no not here
tink tink
can you go neither for here look
carefully can you put the knight on f4
here can we put the knight years no
right pawn takes it see when arrows are
showing you see it just takes it now you
see it what is it yeah but then he takes
back this should takes bishop queen
takes bishop
so something better something better
okay let's see how about this can you
find a move that will attack the Queen
can you find a move that will attack the
Queen a good move
yes perfect attack enchants when we make
a move like this we attack it means we
it called we're gaining a temper okay so
you make this move you attack the Queen
you're gaining a tempo now he can't just
go away because the bishop is hanging
right he can't just go away here because
we just take so he has to go here
Queen d6 and when he plays Queen d6 what
do you do when he plays Queen d6 what do
you do now to win a piece
okay
94 very nice what do we call this in
chess when you're attacking two pieces
at the same time fork or double attack
okay so here it's more like a fork yeah
but the night is forking the bishop and
the Queen so we have to start with
Knight c3 okay it's very important to
start with Knight c3 he goes back with
the Queen ninety four fourteen the Queen
and the bishop okay white to play white
to play and win
now the Czech made you just need to find
a way to win okay but you could also
checkmate in some of the lines so spend
some time first two minutes thinking
before you raise your hand yeah always
remember when you see when you're
playing chess you see a good move
you're on rush to make it same like here
you don't just raise your hand right
away think first check the line make
sure you have the correct answer then
you raise your hand
you
what do you do here huh to win this game
let's see again it's it's yes there is a
defender do you try to eliminate the
defender once you do that then you're
going to be able to checkmate or win
material as well so think about it what
can you do here see you would like to
take this rook right and do a background
check meant but you can't because the
knight is defending it so we find out
that the defender is tonight the night
is actually the defender here that is
defending the rook so what can we do to
make sure we can win this game up let's
see what can we do here think about it
all right let's see yes you could go
Quincy six here right you could do that
that's a probably a good move but you
have something stronger okay something
stronger yes very good
six now you eliminated the defender
right well let's take a look what you
can do here first of all he cannot take
the rook because then you take his queen
so you wrap a queen so this is easy win
so if he takes with the rook what do you
do checkmate into checkmate into check
he comes up you can get also checkmate
you can also go behind him with the
checkmate okay so now if it takes with
the pawn again we go check and checkmate
now let's say he takes it right when
check Bishop is guarding it so now his
best move is going to be Queen takes f6
and if he does this move what do you do
because you just eliminated a defender
right so what do you do
continue yes check he goes back because
he doesn't want to get me so he has to
play rook f8 yes check yeah six
yes and at the end of the combination we
have an extra rope okay so we can easily
win this position okay okay excellent so
we looked at a couple of tactical games
by Magnus calls and the current number
one player in the world by many
considered to be a future world champion
and we did lots of tactics that mix
motifs okay so I recommend you to work
on your own also on doing this kind of
tactics okay
you